you mentioned [ __ ] you money
i i feel like i have [ __ ] you money now
a year ago i was
at zero i have [ __ ] money now because
probably my standards
my i i don't need much in this world but
because also
probably because of you uh but it's 300
to 400 000 people listen to every
episode
i do it's a lot and that result is weird
it's
a successful television show on cable
yeah it's crazy but it's all you yeah
it's hilarious that's amazing but at
this point that also resulted in
fu money in a sense that i don't um
yeah i don't need anything else in this
world but so by way of asking
i've looked up if you've inspired me for
a long time
do you have advice you've done this
on the podcast side of life do you have
advice
for somebody like for me and somebody
like me
going on this journey eric weinstein is
going on this journey
is there advice both
small and big that you have for somebody
like me
the advice is to keep doing what feels
right to you and do
what you're doing obviously it's
resonating with people if you're getting
that big of an audience and i've
listened to your podcast you're very
good at it so
just keep doing it the way you're doing
it um don't let anybody else
get involved what about um you've
connected i think you met jamie at the
comedy store
i met him at the ice house at the ice
house well i think i met him at the
comedy store but then uh we talked at
the ice house
i mean what you'd have to ask him yeah
did you think deeply about
because like you know you basically have
nobody on your team
and and so it almost feels like a
marriage where is it
were you selective about like a j to
somebody to bring into your little
circle
well jamie's exceptional he is he truly
is he's a special
i mean he might have grown i don't
remember how he was in the early days
maybe you could say but
he's definitely better at it but he
right away he's exceptional
he's uh got very little ego yes he's
he's not
a guy who needs a lot of attention he's
not a guy who
um overestimates
uh anything like in terms of like a
negative or positive
like his uh like his his interpretation
of
whether it's uh good things that happen
to the show or bad things that happen
the show he just takes it all
like flat he's chill he's just cool as
[ __ ] and he's so smart
and he's so good as an audio engineer
and as a podcast producer
he's the best but he's basically one of
the only people on you on this whole
team so
yeah how do you find i mean when you let
people in
i mean i'm sure other people wanted to
get involved like why don't you have a
co-host like
you basically kind of well do you well
here's the problem with the co-host
like when you and i are talking when
we're talking i'm
tuned in to you and i'm waiting
to hear what you're saying and i'm
listening and i'm interpreting it
and then i'm calculating whether or not
i have anything to say
whether to let you keep talking whether
i maybe have a question that lets you
expand
further or whether i have a disagreement
or like there's a dance
that's going on now when there's another
person there chiming in too
it [ __ ] the dance up it's like dancing
like if you're doing a dance with
someone
you know like if you're slow dancing
with someone and then a third person's
there stepping on everybody's feet
sometimes it's fun yeah sometimes having
a third person is fun
comedy podcast sometimes it's fun um
kind of structured yeah debate
structures but even then it gets
difficult because people talk over each
other
and also um i find that without
headphones
it's way easier to talk over each other
you make mistakes
yeah you don't you don't hear it the
same way when you have headphones you i
hear what you hear
it's all one sound and i the audience
hears exactly
or rather i hear exactly what the
audience hears whether it's
over here my voice is louder than yours
because you're over there
and if i don't have headphones on it
doesn't it's not all together
at that point one of the interesting
things about your show
is uh you don't almost never have done
and you just generally don't do remote
like
um sorry not remote calls but you don't
go to another person's location
like you've only done a few a small
handful and then just like uh will the
sapolsky he should be
yeah he should do this but i actually we
went back and forth on email i told him
he needs to get your his ass back in
in this in the studio uh he's working on
a book i was a fan of his
a long time ago because i became
obsessed with toxoplasmosis
you know and uh i uh i've reached out to
him
a long time ago before he was willing to
do it but then
i caught him in downtown l.a he was
there for something else and i
just greedily snatched up an hour of his
time
well he doesn't get i think some of
those folks don't get how much magic can
happen in this podcast studio like
bigger than anything they've ever done
in terms of their work
not i'm not talking about reach but in
terms of the discovery of new ideas
there's something magical about
conversation like that
like somebody as brilliant as him if he
gives himself over to the
conversation for multiple hours at a
time that's another place where you've
been inspiration
where i like you know i'm getting more
and more confident
of telling people like an elon musk that
like
you know a lot of ceos are like well he
has 30 minutes on his schedule
i'm like no three hours
[Laughter]
and then they're like so some say no and
then they come back those people have
started coming back to like okay
we're starting to get it they start to
get it and you're
a rare beacon of hope in that sense that
there's some value in long form
they think that nobody wants to listen
for 30 for more than 30 minutes
they think like i have nothing to say
but the reality is
if you just give yourself over to like
the three hours just let it go three
hours four hours whatever it is
there's so much to discover about what
you didn't even know you think
yeah yeah you have to be confident that
you could do
it and in the beginning i just did it
because that's what i wanted to do
and no one was listening so i've always
been a curious person so i've always
i've always
been interested in listening to how
people think about things and how
and talking to people about their
mindset and just
and expanding on my own ideas just
talking
[ __ ] and so we would have these podcasts
and they would go on forever and
my my friend arya i've i never let him
die and never let this die down let him
uh forget this he was always like you
have to edit your podcast i'm telling
you right now you're [ __ ] up
i go why he's like because people are
not going to listen to it i go they
don't have
to yeah i go you listen to part of it he
goes he goes
just do it just i'm telling you trust me
cut it down to like 45 minutes that's
all you need
and i'm like no no i don't think you're
right i i like listening to long-form
things no one knows what kind of time
i go okay i'm gonna do it i'm just gonna
keep doing it this way so
and and uh no he doesn't listen
his are like two and a half hours long
now you won
but you wouldn't like say i mentioned to
you this before this is going to happen
it's actually made a lot of progress
towards it i'm going to talk to putin
but you wouldn't travel to putin if you
want to talk to you putin is a dangerous
character he's not he's not you're
talking to
ever seen the uh thing with uh jerry
craft where they stole his super bowl
ring
yeah yeah that was i think that was a
little bit of a misunderstanding oh
really
i think it's a little bit he just
decided he's gonna steal that super bowl
ring
kind of i think it was a kind of he
thought can i see your ring
he shows him his ring then he puts it on
says i can murder somebody with this
ring so he and then he walks off with it
it's possibly he did it
uh as a he's a big believer in displays
of power
yeah so like it's possible he did that
but on
i think he sees himself as like uh
a tool with which to demonstrate that
russia
still belongs on the stage of the big
players
and so he a lot of the actions selected
through that
lens but in terms of a human being
outside of any of the evils that he may
or may not have done
he is a really thoughtful intelligent
fun human being like the wit uh and
the depth from the jre perspective is
really interesting i'm like his manager
now selling
the he's a judo trying to get trump he's
really good at judo
i have seen him practice judo he's he's
a legit black belt and not only that
he loves it not just skill wise but to
talk about it to reason about it to
think about it
to mma as well so yeah it'd be uh it'd
be a good conversation but you wouldn't
travel to him
[Laughter]
well this holds your principle so that's
the core of the advice
i would rather here's the thing
there's not a person that i have to have
on the show right
and i'm happy to talk to anybody i'm
just as happy to talk to you
as i am to talk to trump as i am
probably more happy to talk to you
as i am to talk to mike tyson as i am to
talk to joey diaz i like talking to
people
i enjoy doing podcasts i enjoy talking
to a variety of people
and i schedule them based on i want to
like i try not to get too many right
wing people in a row or too many
progressive people in a row i don't want
to get repetitive
try not to get too many fighters in a
row i try to balance it out not too many
comedians
comedians are the one one group where i
can have three four in a row five in a
row because that's my tribe
you know those are my people it's easy
we can talk about anything
you